one of our users just gave a super chat
and he kind of said
what i was going to ask you but he gave
scripture behind it which is kind of
interesting
i'd love to know what this user's name
is by the way because i can't every time
i say cove 12x12 if you can let us know
who you are so i can call you by your
first name or whatever name you'd like
to be called i want to give you that
credit
he says taking a position in the middle
is interesting the bible mentions
because you are lukewarm
and neither hot nor cold i am going to
vomit you out of my mouth middle is safe
hot or cold is risky so the way i would
say to someone like you is for someone
do you think um
the position you took
at this stage of your life you can tell
me pat you have no clue with your time i
screw you i'm very happy where i'm at
and i'm totally okay with that do you
think you took a safe position from 22
till today the last 58 years or do you
think
you
you
you
could have gone a little bit deeper to
[Music]
really make the argument stronger
amongst different denominations and
evolut you know evolution
or no you're very satisfied with the
position you took
very satisfied i mean
sure you know what i'm asking well from
a rhetorical point of view i would never
affirm i'm very satisfied that that um
is too um
to to vulgar a position even from me
um no i'm not i'm not very satisfied i'm
not satisfied at all but i at the same
time i am not motivated
i don't have that urgency of desire
which would lead me to a full-fledged
religious commitment urgency or i don't
have that urgency or desire is that what
you said i don't know urgency of desire
of desire you never had it or you don't
have it current
i don't think i ever had it look uh
mathematical talent is fairly rare
when you look at the bell curve the
really really tested people yeah are all
the way off in the right yep
um
the number of people who are genuinely
motivated by a religious instinct i
think is about as rare it's a fully
consuming commitment i don't disagree
i don't disagree it's a fully consuming
commitment you cannot say
i'm leading a religious life and lead
the life of a scoundrel
it's very difficult i mean you can you
you can lead the life of a scoundrel and
expect or at least hope for divine
forgiveness but it's not a particularly
salutary combination
um
i think in all the all the areas talent
mathematics talent and our talent music
talent and religious experience
the number of people who are seriously
committed
all the way off on the the right hand
side of the bell curve
if you go back to the 12th 13th and 14th
century
the number of people who embraced
a true monastic life
it's about the same as the number of
people who embrace that life in the 20th
century small percentage of the
population
it's a it's a great mistake to talk
about the christian middle ages as if
virtually everyone is interested in it
was deeply involved i mean there was a
reigning ideology that's for sure well
well you know what it's like the way you
said it made sense like being seven feet
tall and having zero interest in
basketball you're like listen i'm not
interested in basketball i want to do
you know complete different game i'm not
i want to play tennis i don't want to
play basketball so
you know i didn't i didn't mean to say i
don't want to i think it's
like i i certainly
would acknowledge
certain desires certain wants
which are unfulfillable
for example i would dearly love to be a
great great mathematician inscribed in
all the history books having produced a
thunderously magnificent set of
demonstrations it's not going to happen
no matter how much i want it to happen
i think in terms of religious experience
there there is certainly some desire
there for a committed religious
experience but
it's not going to happen either because
i can't act on it if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]